well tonight many of you have been
reaching out to us saying hospitals in
the valley are canceling your elective
surgery now to clarify elective
surgeries can be scheduled in advance
for something you might choose to have
for a better quality of life but not
necessarily a life-threatening condition
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo is
live outside of sunrise hospital with
what doctors and patients are saying
about it sally
doctors i spoke with say they are still
there for their patients and would not
delay any case or situation that could
make their conditions worse
it is a
challenge but we continue to manage our
resources to handle the increase in
demand of the patients requiring our
services dr stephen murtagh with sunrise
wants to assure patients they will get
the treatment they need certain
hysterectomies a patient can delay for a
week or two a certain orthopedic cases
ent ent being ear nose and throat dr
merta does not want to use the word
cancel when it comes to elective
surgeries instead the word is paused any
emergent case that will have an adverse
effect on your body we absolutely are
evaluating and moving forward chelsea
carter just had a knee replacement when
i finally decided to have the surgery
and i knew i had to have the surgery
because
my it had deteriorated my surgeon's
schedule
was pretty filled but they were able to
get me in on the day that i had wanted
carter says when she got to the hospital
she was told the majority of patients in
front of her had canceled i think that
everybody that i know
have decided that anything that they
need will have to wait till the later
date i'm hopeful that we will get
through this fourth surge and we will be
back taking care of all the community
for all their needs
umc sent me a statement
in part it reads
quote during the recent surge of covet
19 cases umc has not postponed any
impatient surgeries emergency surgeries
transplants or cancer surgeries
uncommonly considers postponing certain
elective procedures on a day by day
basis for now reporting live sally
jaramillo 8 news now